[Music]
escaping slavery risking everything to
save her family leading a military raid
championing the cause of women's
suffrage these are just a handful of the
accomplishments of one of America's most
courageous heroes Harriet Tubman was
born Araminta Ross in Dorchester County
Maryland in the early 1820s born into
chattel slavery Araminta or mintee was
the fifth of nine children two of
Minty's older sisters were sold to a
chain gang even as a small child
minty was hired out to different owners
who subjected her to whippings and
punishments
young mentees life changed forever on an
errand to a neighborhood store there an
overseer threw a two-pound weight at a
fugitive enslaved person missed and
struck minty instead her injury caused
her to experience sleeping spells which
we know of today as narcolepsy for the
rest of her life
Minty's owner tried to sell her but
there were no buyers for an enslaved
person who fell into sleeping spells she
was instead put to work with her father
Ben Ross who taught her how to lumber
lumbering increased Minty's physical
strength and put her in touch with free
black sailors who shipped the wood to
the north from then minty learned about
the secret communication that occurred
along trade routes information that
would prove invaluable later in her life
in this mixed atmosphere of free and
enslaved blacks working side-by-side
mintee met John Tubman a free black man
she married in 1844 after marriage she
renamed herself Harriet after her mother
Harriet Tubman's owner died in 18-49
when his widow planned to sell off her
enslaved human beings
Harriet feared she would be sold away
from everyone she loved she had heard of
an underground railroad a secret network
of safe houses boat captains and wagon
drivers willing to harbor fugitive
enslaved people on their way north
so Tubman fled with two of her brother's
Ben and Harry they eventually turned
back fearing they were lost but in one
of her sleeping spells Harriet dreamed
that she could fly like a bird looking
down below she saw the path to
liberation and in the autumn of 18-49
she set out on her own following the
North Star to Pennsylvania and to
freedom
Tubman returned to the South thirteen
times to free her niece brothers parents
and many others she earned the nickname
black Moses and worked diligently with
fellow abolitionists to help enslaved
people escape first to the north and
later to Canada Harriet Tubman worked as
a Union Army nurse scout and spy during
the Civil War in 1863 she became the
first woman in United States history to
plan and lead a military raid liberating
nearly 700 and slaved persons in South
Carolina after the war the Thirteenth
Amendment to the United States
Constitution legally abolished slavery
while the 14th expanded citizenship and
the 15th gay voting rights to formerly
enslaved black men but she was undaunted
and she persisted she raised funds for
formerly enslaved persons and helped
build schools and a hospital on their
behalf in 1888 Tubman became more active
in the fight for women's right to vote
in 1896 she appeared at the founding
convention of the National Association
of colored women in Washington DC and
later at a women's suffrage meeting new
Rochester New York there she told the
audience I was a conductor on the
Underground Railroad and I can say what
many others cannot I never ran my train
off the track and I never lost a
passenger as her fame grew various
friends and allies helped her in the
fight to collect a veteran's pension for
her service in the Union Army in 1899
she was finally granted $20 a month in a
fitting twist of fate the United States
Treasury announced in 2016 that Tubman's
image will appear on a redesigned $20
bill Harriet Tubman died on March 10th
1913 even on her deathbed at age 91 she
kept the freedom of her people in mind
her final words were I go away to
prepare a place for you if you are
inspired by Harriet Tubman's life in
work we highly recommend the Pulitzer
Prize winning novel the Underground
Railroad this wildly inventive and
courageous book follows protagonist Cora
through the trials and horrors of
escaping slavery in the South you can
download an audio version of the book
for free at audible.com
every free trial created encourages
audible to continue supporting Ted Ed's
nonprofit mission